decorating cakes can be really easy
you don't have to shell out a lot of
money to make something that looks
really fun and beautiful and to prove it
we're going to show you
five easy cake decorating techniques to
make you look like a total pro
[Music]
starting with our crumb coat this is
basically just a layer of frosting to
tighten up our canvas
you're going to want to coat your cake
evenly but it definitely doesn't have to
be perfect because
we're just gonna cover this up anyway
you might notice your cake is starting
to lean
but that's okay just nudge it around
until it's straight
when you add your last layer make sure
you turn it upside down
so that the top of the cake is nice and
flat once you're built up
just finish covering your cake in
buttercream you can do this
with or without a piping bag doesn't
matter as
long as you get your cake fully coated
when you're done let it chill in the
fridge before you start decorating
for the shag cake you'll need a grass
piping tip that looks like this
you're going to add this to a piping bag
and then you're going to add one color
of buttercream frosting you'll need at
least
four different colors for this design
and they can be whatever you choose
our inspiration for this cake was the
mystery machine from scooby-doo
starting with your first color put your
piping bag right up against the cake
push
down applying even pressure to the
piping bag
and pull straight out while releasing
you're trying to create
clusters of grass so just build each one
in almost
a stacking triangle or pattern it's okay
if your first few
aren't the best the grass may not be
greener on the other side
but it'll definitely be easier to make
by the time you get over there
if you do happen to mess up like we did
here
no worries just put your piping bag
right up over the space
and try again this is a really easy
technique because your imperfections
just look like they're part of the cake
move on to the other colors as you see
fit and create whatever pattern you like
there's no real rhyme or reason here
we're just kind of filling it in where
we see fit
and you can switch your colors whenever
you want to
[Music]
there you have it folks your finished
shag cake
it's so simple and easy you can really
get creative
and experiment with the designs on this
cake it's
very easy to customize and we absolutely
recommend you try it
let's try a watercolor technique next
start with a crumb coat that's already
been chilled
add a second layer of buttercream
frosting before you start decorating
this time
the second coat is going to be visible
under our watercolor so be a little bit
more
precious with it than you were with the
crumb coat you're going to need
two different colors for this design
starting with your first color
use an offset spatula to swipe dollops
of buttercream
all over your cake
try to offset each swipe if you have any
cracks or imperfections in your bottom
coat
cover them up with dabs of colored
buttercream add your second color of
buttercream in those empty spaces
we don't want any swatch to be too close
to the other
you're going to use light pressure to
slowly blend the swatches of buttercream
together
let it build up on your tool this will
help the colors blend and really just
keep smoothing it from here
it's up to you what you want it to look
like the more you smooth the more colors
are going to blend
so if you want something bright and
striking we'd say
less is more you can always add more
swipes of color as you go
[Music]
just repeat the same steps from the top
and then
smooth to your heart's desire think of
the motion
up here as nice sweeping curves this
cake is giving us a little bit of
springing the winter
time so here's how we're going to
complete the look we combined our
remaining buttercream
inside a piping bag and we're going to
use that to create a ribbon border now
apply
even pressure to your piping bag and
move in a very subtle
circular motion and then top it off with
some flowers
no rhyme or reason here just do what
makes you happy
[Applause]
topping off your cake with flowers is
usually a safe bet
and those flowers look so good
let's take a break from crumb coats and
talk flower piping techniques
to make some beautiful buttercream roses
you're going to need this petal piping
tip
add that to your piping bag and then
fill it with red buttercream frosting
now this is called a flower nail it's
just a very handy tool that's going to
make it really easy to sculpt our roses
first place a dab of buttercream on the
nail and place a square of parchment
paper on top
touch the wide end of the tip to the
base of the flower nail and the narrow
end
should point up an angle slightly inward
squeeze
the bag and rotate the nail use even
pressure to squeeze out the next petal
touch the tip to the base of the center
bud and rotate the nail
as you squeeze creating ribbons that
wrap halfway around
make sure each new petal overlaps the
one before it
and there you have it buttercream roses
but you know what we're feeling festive
so
let's do some poinsettias next the only
thing you'll need different is this leaf
piping tip create leaves by squeezing
hard at the base and then release the
pressure
as you pull out poinsettias have five
leaves at the bottom
and another five stacked on top to
really sell it
we're going to add gold sprinkles right
in the center of our leaves
perfect now we're just going to put all
of our flowers on a baking sheet
and transfer them to the fridge to chill
to complete this technique we use this
basket weave piping tip and filled our
piping bag with white buttercream
but hey dealer's choice you'll need a
second coat of buttercream
on your cake before you start decorating
and when you're ready
take your piping bag and use even
pressure to pipe out
one long strip straight down now do a
shorter horizontal strip
over that keep making this horizontal
strips all the way down
leaving an empty space about the size of
the piping tip
in between each strip now make your next
vertical strip
down covering one edge of those
horizontal strips
start your next set of horizontal
stripes by burying the piping tip
under the previous vertical line now
it's just repeating the pattern from
here
keep creating your lines and stripes
until you've completely covered your
cake
now you could stop right here if you've
never decorated a cake before
this is way beyond impressive but take
it up a notch and bring back those
poinsettias and roses that we made
earlier and decorate the top of your
cake with flowers
now that looks great for these empty
spaces
we're going to bring back our leaf
piping tip filled with
green buttercream we're going to create
some leaves in there
using the same technique we use to
create our poinsettias just squeeze
hard at the base and release pressure as
you pull out
now that is an awesome cake it feels
very festive because of the colors that
we used but you can recreate this
technique for
any occasion in any color that you like
and it's going to look
great guaranteed now let's finish up
with an easy approach to a geode cake
add a second layer of buttercream on top
of your crumb coat ours is blue and we
save some of that blue frosting to use
to decorate with later this is our rock
candy that we're going to use for our
geode pattern and this is blue food
coloring and vodka
which we'll use to dye our candy using a
small serrated knife
carve out a space in the cake where your
rock candy will sit
you can make this whichever size you
prefer just clean out the space so it's
a bit more even but it doesn't have to
be perfect because we're going to use
that extra buttercream we saved to cover
this back up
once that's recoated it's time to add
our rock candy just cover up
any space that you see and press down
firm to make sure the rock candy sits in
your frosting wall
now for that vodka and food coloring
mixture take a little bit
and paint it on the innermost wall of
the rock candy this is going to give
your cake
more depth you'll need to chill this for
about 20 minutes before doing
anything else to jazz it up a little
we're going to add
gold leaf around the edges
all of these cakes can be easily
customized to match your style
and the techniques will get easier and
easier the more you try them
for more cake decorating techniques
check out our
other tasty video five beautiful ways to
decorate a cake
for more delicious baking content follow
fluff cups on instagram
if you try any of these techniques at
home make sure you tag
us on all your recreations
oh yes
you